scientists say volcanic events may have
helped trap water in rocks from the
moon's dusty surface it happened
billions of years ago researchers say
there could be as much water in the
moon's mantle as beneath the earth's
crust Jan Crawford shows us why
supporters of manned space exploration
are so excited by the discovery she's at
the Smithsonian National Air and Space
Museum in Washington Jan good morning
well good morning so these new findings
are really up ending decades of our
understanding about our closest neighbor
in space the analysis suggests that the
water on the interior moon actually
means it's pretty wet and that could
help make it it's easier for us to fly
there and back or even stay a while for
decades scientists have thought the moon
was a dry dusty place it may be time to
rewrite the astronomy books this is a
recent picture of the moon's surface by
measuring the reflecting light
researchers at Brown University were
able to detect water molecules in the
colored areas red and yellow indicates a
high concentration planetary geologist
Ralph Milliken is the lead author of the
study some of these deposits that we
observe on the moon spend thousands of
square kilometers absolutely enormous it
works like this when the moon was young
and still volcanically active violent
eruptions released water molecules
trapped in the moon's mantle as the
magma cooled the molecules became
trapped again this time inside volcanic
glass beads embedded in moon rocks left
behind on the surface a similar process
happens when volcanoes erupt here on
earth on the moon Millikan says most of
the water is dispersed deep below the
crust locked away in its rocky interior
we can bake that water out of those
rocks
Derek Pitts chief astronomer at the
Franklin Institute says the moon's water
could be used for drinking
as well as provide oxygen for breathing
and hydrogen for rocket fuel we wouldn't
have to carry so many basic commodities
to the moon which turns out to be one of
the most expensive things we can do in
space exploration to actually get say a
liter of water you probably have to mine
in harvest maybe one to three hundred
cubic feet of material an important
question all of that would be is it
economically feasible to do so now Ralph
Milliken still says that discovery those
large amounts of water on the moon
probably wouldn't support life as we
know it he said the conditions there are
still pretty inhospitable to the kind of
organisms that we have here on earth
Nora all right Jan thank you it's good
to know if you two decide to go the moon
that you could get some water shirley
maclaine just said once all you need is
a good hat water and a good pair of
shoes there you go and what more than
that yeah